no justice no peace no racist police no
justice I
am I
am I can't Brea I can't Brea jail killer
cop jail killer cops it's important to
be out here just to express frustration
and outrage at the at the entire system
and how uh how stacked it is against
black black boys and I have I'm a mother
of two black boys so it's important to
me to be here I mean anybody but
especially anyone black young black boys
really needs to think about how we talk
to them about police you're supposed to
grow up thinking police are heroes and I
can't tell him that cuz it's not true
and he's he's four years old and he
shouldn't have to know what happened but
but we told him because you know he's
going to grow up in New York City and uh
I'm worried about his safety you know a
lot of my students and a lot of people I
know feel less safe when police are
around than more safe and that's that's
really sick and it says something
terrible about our society street street
street street street street and we're
protest
for my man Eric Gardner who passed away
in [__] um Sten Island police
officer chok him out and tonight we came
to tell the police [__] them this ain't
going to be the last time they see us
like you know what I mean good people a
good person was hurt Eric was hurt we
were affected by something a bad person
did so all the good people in the world
we need to do this and separate from the
bad people all I can say is this this is
has been an absolute nightmare for
people of African descent people say oh
yeah I understand no you don't I'm here
because I know if we have strength if we
have direction we can really make change
it's not some BS it's the real deal
people will hear our voice we will grow
in numbers and we will overcome no
peace
Poli
up up
up don't shoot hands up don't shoot
hands up don't
shoot thank you
s thank
you right
on
now you look
dumb